un derby pour croire à la montée en fin
de saison ce dimanche 15 mai montigny le
bretonneux recevait but en cours sur son
terrain à l'occasion de la 20e journée
de d2 de district appliquée lésigny
montant se procure des occasions sur
cette première période sans faire sauter
le verrou guillon courtois le score à la
pause 0 à 0 alors comment difficilement
rencontre mais après le premier quart
d'heure on s'est bien repris
j'ai une très grosse opportunité je
pense que si si on marque le mat il est
pas pareil donc un peu frustrant mais
c'est cette première période où on
s'observe un petit peu il ya une équipe
qui est très en place continue que très
difficile à jouer avec un gros bloc avec
un gros bloc beaucoup de joueurs au
milieu du terrain en seconde période la
dynamique s'inverse lui en cours pouces
mais n'arrive pas à marquer face aux
verts le score n'évoluera pas score
final 0 à 0 un show comme ça je dirais
beaucoup de frustration parce que
j'estime qu'on aurait dû faire beaucoup
mieux on aura je pense qu'on a dominé ce
match on a pas mal de situations et on a
raté beaucoup de deux derniers gestes
dernière passe mauvais contrôle pense
que dans l'ensemble un dominé ce match
on a manqué d'efficacité offensive
matyassy recrutera pas ce qu'on avait
deux équipes qui se valent et nous on
avait à coeur de pas de gagner ce match
parce que c'est un derby ce match nul
n'arrange aucune des deux équipes du en
cours est sous pression pour conserver
sa troisième place au classement sur son
côté montigny le bretonneux pourrait ne
pas monter en fin de saison lésiné
montant joueront un match crucial à
domicile face à houilles le nouveau
leader le 29 mai prochain